this is one of the most outrageous and
also chilling stories
about press freedom and treatment of
activists
and journalists the belarusian or bella
russian
president alexander lukashenko ordered a
fighter jet to escort a passenger flight
operated by ryanair
to the ground in minsk belarus so that a
specific passenger
on that flight rahman pratasivic
an exiled critic of lukashenko
could be arrested now you might be
asking well what was
pratosovich doing flying to belarus
knowing that an arrest could be what is
going to happen
at the tail end of it well the answer is
that he actually was not that is not
actually what he was doing this was a
ryanair flight flight number 4978
uh ryanair is a european low-cost
carrier which
is not exactly a pleasure to fly on i
will tell you the flight was scheduled
to go from athens greece
to vilnius lithuania but it just so
happens that this flight
flies over bella russian airspace and
belarus
launched a fighter jet to intercept the
plane have it land
in minsk belarus every passenger was
removed one explanation that
was apparently given although i'll get
back to this is that there was a quote
potential security threat on board
so bella russian authorities have
everybody get off the plane they check
everything and they say great news
everything's fine
after five hours on the ground it was a
false alarm everybody can leave
everybody gets back on the plane but not
really everybody one passenger wasn't
there when they reboarded after the five
hours on the ground in minsk rahman
pratasavik
was not there was taken into custody and
did not re-board the plane
now afterwards the ryanair flight took
off for vilnius
um and everything resumed quote as
normal and we'll talk about ryanair's
explanation for what took place
so who is this rahman pratasavik
pratasivik is the founder of the
telegram channel nexta
which was used to organize anti
belarusian government protests um
another similar channel critical of the
government was
all also run by protosavic both are
classified as
extremists in belarus and pratosovic is
also on a government-wanted list
for terrorism but belarus has a strong
man authoritarian in power
who has been in power since 1994 was
abruptly inaugurated
into office for the sixth time in a row
last september following
a disputed election that the eu said was
not
a legitimate election and amid mass
protests in belarus last summer
lukashenko and the state security
apparatus started
removing from the country or detaining
leading opposition
figures and now they've grounded a plane
forcibly
to take an activist off of it now
there's another really wacky part to
this story
the statement that was put out by
ryanair about the flight
makes no mention of the fact that they
were strong-armed by an authoritarian
government that has been in power for
nearly 30 years and that one of their
passengers was taken off the flight
the ryanair press office tweeted quote
our flight
4978 has landed safely in vilnius at 7
25 pm local time our uk time
9 25 local time here is ryanair's
statement on today's diversion to minsk
airport and when you read it
it sounds like nothing really happened
it just says um
the crew on a ryanair flight to vilnius
today were notified by belarus
about a potential security threat on
board and
were instructed to divert to the nearest
airport
that was minsk the aircraft landed
safely passengers were offloaded
security checks were completed by locals
nothing untoward was found and
authorities cleared the craft to depart
together
with passengers and crew after about oh
seven hours on the ground i had said
five in minsk
the airport departed the aircraft
departed for vilnius at 1850 uk time and
landed at 1925 uk time ryanair has
notified the relevant national and
european safety and security agencies
we apologize sincerely to all affected
it's like
there wasn't someone pulled off after
the flight was escorted to land
by a fighter jet rather um it was just
uh
oh check and everything was fine and no
big deal and the other
thing about this that's raising red
flags is nobody's even on the same page
about what happened
story one was there was a potential
threat so the plane landed and they
checked
whether there really was a threat the
minsk airport
told russian state media ria navasti
that the plane made an emergency landing
because of an unconfirmed
bomb threat but then a spokesperson for
lithuanian airports
said to lrt national radio that the
landing was because there was a conflict
on the flight between a passenger and
one of the
of the crew members completely different
explanations now the eu and the u.s have
condemned
this arrest and how it took place this
is really
the stuff of horrors and as a passenger
i'd be furious at the delay
besides the politics flying with ryanair
is horrible
and i avoid it whenever possible now
they made me have two flights really
i'm kidding around obviously that's not
really the important thing here
this is really horrifying it is
dystopian and we're going to follow it
but are we ever going to hear from
rahman
tavik again i don't know the answer to
that and as of right now we don't know
exactly what fate awaits him
or has already uh been been carried out
against him so
scary stuff and just a bizarre uh
whitewashed sort of statement from
ryanair
and we will presumably learn more about
this as the days go on
one of our sponsors today is bluechew a
unique
online service delivering the same
active
ingredients as viagra and cialis in a
chewable form and at a fraction of the
cost
and they're giving my audience an entire
month supply for free
so if you think you could benefit from
an extra boost
of confidence when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days
in a discreet package no driving around
to the doctor's office or the pharmacy
no waiting around
no awkward conversations with your
doctor all of blue chews tablets are
made
in the usa the entire process is just a
few clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire
month's supply for free when you use the
promo code
pacman all you have to do is pay five
dollars shipping